Jim hurtling is an American who knows
more about the differences between the
United States and Paris and anyone I
know for years with Bloomberg News joins
us from our London News Bureau Jim
you've got just fabulous perspective
here how does this play differently than
if this terrorist attack occurred in New
York or Miami wow that's a great
question tom in it and it really it
remains to be seen because the the early
the early reports we know as a terrorist
attack at least the president president
alone said so right now French
television is reporting that that the
alleged attackers chanted or yelled out
the prophet has been avenged as they ran
out and they remain at large so a lot
will depend upon what the investigation
shows about what actually happened frame
for us the difference Jim hurtling
between domestic Islamist in France and
a more international international
relations that we look at today are they
closely linked or is the French
experience with Muslims so different
from the news flow of the last six
months well France is is has grown
incredibly concerned because there's a
there's a large number of Muslims in
France and throughout Europe who have
gone to Syria to join the fight there
and there's a tremendous concern among
authorities in in France and elsewhere
in Europe about those trained fighters
cycling cycling back to Europe and
bringing their their heightened ideology
and their heightened fighting skills
back to write back to Europe the gym
early let me bring in scarlet through
you two have known each other for a few
years We certainly have JAMA Charlie
Hebdo the satirical weekly that was
targeted in this attack had been
attacked before in a fire bombing
incident in 2011 our media companies Jim
particularly a high terrorism target and
frantic you ever feel unsafe when you
learn when you worked at Bloomberg in
Paris no I certainly didn't feel unsafe
but Charlie Hebdo went out of its way
to to ruffle feathers you'll recall they
published those cartoons of Prophet
Muhammad a few years ago that that
raised so many hackles and the
cartoonist char boohoo what does he mean
to France you know France holds its
freedom of press very dearly much as
they do much as we do in the US and
along the president alone himself said
that the Charlie Hebdo offices were
under a heightened protection even
before this attack